[Musique]
madame monsieur bonjour bonjour à tous
bonjour à tous l'invité de sa or qu'a
dit ce matin philippe petit bonjour
allez-vous oui bonjour vous êtes le
président de l'udinese martinique c'est
bien ça oui et dès les fils et
petit-fils est candidat du causse
oui j'ai envoyé la pression du chat
trois semaines un mail et avec un petit
tract qui a été distribué dans les
boîtes aux lettres de ducos et qui
annoncé ma candidature n'avait pas
hésité un moment quand même oui parce
que s'ils voulaient c'est un concours de
circonstances qui fait que je suis
candidat et parce que le maire s'en va
donc il faut profiter de cette
opportunité là alors vous m'aviez
interrogez-vous même d'ailleurs 2018
c'est peut-être vous il ya un an ou un
an et demi qui m'avait mis la puce à
l'oreille parce que j'étais
tranquillement la et j'observais le
paysage politique
et puis je vous avais dit d'ailleurs
dans cette interview que j'attendais
puisque entre temps j'ai pris ma
retraite
le juge est ce que je ferai de mon temps
libre est de savoir si effectivement la
politique et moi nous continuons puisque
je suis avant tout vous le savez un
militant très bien philippe thys effect
combien de fois que vous présentez à
ducos et mais je meurs au conte
probablement je sais pas si c'est le
recours de la menthe unique mais c'est
la cinquième fois et si vous voulez g2g
deux paramètres qui me permet de dire
que malgré tout ce n'est pas tout à fait
ce n'est pas le premier paramètre c'est
une anecdote je suis en train de
distribuer un tract grande savane quand
il du cos et monsieur m'a dit mais tu
viens pour la cinquième fois je dis oui
manitou p il me dit non tu as des
convictions vous voyez le comment ça
peut passer dans la population pour deux
là n'ont pas de l'acharnement mais tout
simplement de la conviction
le maire de le maire du havre de
l'époque celui gabris et d'edouard
philippe s'appelle antoine ruffenach il
a été lui aussi pour l'anecdote un
puisque j'avais entendu ça à l'époque à
cinquième fois donc on verra si c'est la
bonne
cinq fois cinq échecs c'est pas
c'est cette fois quatre échecs c'est pas
décourageant c'est si vous voulez alors
soit on appelle ça échec son appel
expérience j'ai souvent des discussions
avec des gens c'est l'expérience de la
vie et j'ai une phrase qui dédient qui
dit toujours il n'est pas nécessaire
d'espérer pour entreprendre ni de
réussir pour persévérer
je suis un homme d'action je suis dans
l'associatif depuis 20 ans je suis dans
le boulot dans la politique depuis 25
ans je crois qu'on n'ose pas poser ce
genre de questions des fois par exemple
manjoo h en ou lorsqu'elle est à la fois
dans un combat syndical qui était dans
un combat politique on ne s'est jamais
posé la question de savoir si elle
échoué ou bien si tout simplement c'est
être une militante je suis exactement
une comme madame johanne où j'avais déjà
dit d'ailleurs tout simplement je suis
un militant plus modérée je suis
centriste
il ya des valeurs qui sait ce qu'il veut
est ce qu est ce qui nous motive encore
quand même alors vous êtes à la retraite
vous auriez pu google couler des jours
paisibles faire des croisières
alors si je vous répondrai dans mon
intimité privé jeunes et pourquoi pas
vous dire que mon épouse n'est pas en
quoi la retraite donc quand elle m'a dit
quand je lui dit qu'est ce que tu en
penses elle m'a dit je sais que les gens
de ducos forcément ne te comprennent pas
mais vaut mieux aller plutôt guillou et
gaga est là donc j l'assentiment de mon
épouse c'est le premier a certainement
le deuxième très avance c'est important
dans la vie le deuxième c'est la base de
ducos et un certain nombre de jeunes qui
m'ont dit philippe je te vois bien mr je
leur ai demandé pourquoi la manière dont
tu te comportes avec nous parce que j'ai
tissé des relations un moment donné en
étant prises le club de foot en étant
relativement ouvert avec eux et vu la
troisième je suis aussi président de
l'udps est une fédération de la menthe
nique et nous recevons la semaine
prochaine le député lagarde
on va y revenir d'accord donc le député
lagarde qui est président de l'ue dit
m'a confié une mission
il faut porter le territoire exactement
et il faut monter le territoire mais
dans la mesure où nous avons deux
mouvements politiques le sien lui dit
est le mien qui s'appelle le mouvement
libéral populaire ancien mouvement
libéral menti ni qu'est qu'on avait
rebaptisé long du 74 73 qui le
souhaitent nous étions contre le 74 en
avait profité pour le rebaptisera le
profil et vous avez vous êtes passé
mlp vous avez été du centre droit
ensuite vous avait flirté un peu avec le
centre gauche maintenant lui dit alors
constantin alors quand il ya une
constance tout à fait c'est que je suis
centriste où l'avez bien compris
l'alliance avec un mouvement national je
n'ai jamais dit vous n'avez pas vu mon
étiquette avec l'indépendance
vous n'avez pas vu mon étiquette avec
l'autonomie d'ailleurs ce qui n'est pas
l'un des palaces on avait vu toujours
libéral souple donc quand une personne
l'europe est assez monsieur jego qui
était venu à la menthe inique il avait
deux candidats à l'époque mon ami
maurice laouchez et philippe petit les
seuls qui était assez suicidé à bout
s'occuper du centre qui pèse très peu à
la martinique
il a choisi le plus idéal et 2 philippe
petit
depuis je suis resté j'ai été élu début
2014 président réélu en 2016 puis dans
la fédération 10 2 ans prend 2018 à
nouveau élu de la fédération indique
donc j'ai accompli mon devoir et je
pense que les dossiers si jamais je suis
maire de lugos pourront remonter plus
facilement vers la métropole plus
facilement dans l'hémicycle plus
facilement vers les ministères et je
pense donc que ça serait un bonheur pour
du causse de m'avoir comme est-ce qu'il
a beau geste qui a besoin d'être élu
maire pour faire remonter le dossier
parce qu'on a on a vu alors on suivra en
parler avec l'octroi de mer ya neuf de
dix attaques alors que lui dit proche du
gouvernement il ya des attaques
on a vu avec
je vous demander votre réaction avec la
prime de vie chère aussi est-ce qu'il ya
besoin d'être obligatoirement élus pour
faire remonter des dossiers alors b
alors vous faites appel à la notion de
démocratie représentative qui ne serait
pas vous faites comme un gilet jaune je
n'ai rien contre les jets les jeunes à
chacun mais sa revendication pour les
jeux version jeune belge il ya une
dimension si les jeunes je ne suis pas
un gilet jaune je vous pose juste des
questions alors une démocratie
représentative
puis une démocratie participative
participative c'est quand vous faites le
vous réunion de quartier que vous n'êtes
pas anticiper votre peuple
votre population à la gestion de la
commune pour savoir les projets et
ensuite la démocratie représentative
ce sont les gens qui exécutent c'est à
dire que pour cela ceux qui sont en
charge des dossiers il faut qu'il soit
élu c'est mieux que ce qui s'est mieux
agathe de vous entendre c'est mieux si
vous alerter sur le problème parce que
vous n'êtes pas élu
sam beaucoup plus de poids que bien
entendu que je m'entends mais ça a
beaucoup plus de poids quand vous pouvez
défendre vos dossiers vous même dans
l'état actuel de ducos que vous avez vu
le résident de l'état vous concernant
dans les tailles effet rendez-vous
dossier comme dans l'état actuel de
ducos aujourd'hui puisque nous avons
parlé de municipal
vous avez vu qu'il ya ça ne vous échappe
pas échappé à la population du co 16 et
à tous les candidats d'ailleurs qu'il y
à des observations de plus sur les
exercices de 2009 à 2017
comment voulez vous remontez les
déficits qui a si vous voulez bien qu'on
en parle je sais pas si c'est le le
l'objet du jour si vous n'avez pas la
possibilité de mère d'aller frapper un
certain nombre de portes
c'est à dire que c'est pas le tout
d'avoir des dossiers il faut les
accompagner votre présence physique
votre énergie votre capacité de
persuasion font que ces dossiers seront
plus entendu c'est comme ça parce que
tout le monde a des difficultés dans
tout l'est avec la dgf vous auriez vous
êtes capable de faire remonter
par exemple si vous allez vous savez il
ya des communes qui ont eu les
équipements il ya des communes qui n'ont
pas d'équipement
un exemple vous allez me dire que c'est
un rapport de force interne mais c'est
pour vous donner un exemple quand vous
voyez que en 20 ans depuis enfin je sais
pas depuis combien de temps créé
l'espace sud pire ça fait pas vingt ans
que vous avez vu que nous avons une
piste cyclable qui n'est même pas
utiliser qui a été inauguré deux ou
trois fois qu'il n'aime pas utilisable
par ce que il n'y a pas eu de rapport de
force de la mairie de ducos qui donne le
plus gros budget à l'espace sud et
qu'elle n'a en échange sur un certain
nombre d'années que ça ça veut dire
qu'il n'ya pas eu si vous voulez le
lobby n'y a pas eu de persuasion le
projet porté au niveau de l'espace sud
est mais c'est exactement la même chose
au niveau de l'état ça veut dire que
ceux qui ne se fait pas à l'espace une
vous ne le ferez pas non plus haut
niveau de l'état où il ya aussi les
subventions récupérer je donne un
exemple je vais faire je vais monter par
exemple un spectacle son et lumière sur
la cuisine et des états et la rue
principale de ducos où il ya eu à
l'époque un assassinat de charles jean
et de l'un des étages par le gendarme
roquettes
admettons que vous vouliez façon que je
voulais faire un spectacle culturel qui
permettrait disons une fois par mois
peut être saison touristique peut être
une fois par semaine et bien de remonter
votre spectacle comme l'a fait philippe
de villiers pour le puy du fou en france
et que vous puissiez dire que voulait
faire ce spectacle que vous voulez le
monte qui vous faut donc des figurants
aussi bien anonyme mais bien entendu
bénévoles que des figurants payés ou
est-ce que vous allez prendre l'argent
sur ministère de la culture
ça veut dire que vous mettez sur le
biais de la culture et vous mettez ce
spectacle par exemple sur le plan
national
exactement comme le puy du fou et même
internationale de même les champs de
vision pas élu et qui ont des projets
alors juste parce que les gens qui
disent que la série d'affilée offs à se
faire financer comme les gens qui ne
sont pas élus chrétiens des productions
des associations
donc ces mêmes sociales sont toujours
implantés associativement ducos parce
que j'avais eu l'impression que vous
étiez un peu des engagés et que vous
étiez retourner à redoute à fort de
france
je suis je suis
un homme de parole et un passionné de
choses notamment le football
il se trouve que j'ai été président
pendant un certain nombre d'années sans
aucune subvention de la mairie de ducos
d'un club de football pendant 13 ans à
la fin comme on n'avait aucune
subvention pour des raisons extra
sportives
nous avons mis la clé sous la porte on
m'a récupéré un moment donné aux doutes
j'ai fait trois ans en ce moment je suis
président de l'association du lamentin
monde pitot je le fais avec bonheur en
fonction des demandes
je ne fais pas d'entrisme je ne fus
mélange pas politique et associatif
d'accord donc à partir de ce moment là
je suis toujours puissante association
donc je vais dire que je prends mon je
m'en prends mon pied en tout cas
j'essaie de défendre les valeurs de des
associations c'est à dire les valeurs
d'équité les valeurs de sportivité
essayez d'éduquer les jeunes et
d'encadrer les jeunes donc je fais mon
rôle locale romeu 3d jour du cos donc
quand vous me le demandez
j'ai habité du coach et du nord qu'elle
gère la plantation à ducos alors vous
êtes plus mous présidents d'associations
vous n'habitez plus la commune vous êtes
implantées ou à ducos je vais vous dire
j'ai voté d'anecdotes quand je suis venu
me présenter à ducos c'est tout
simplement qu'on est venu me chercher
j'ai été pas anti à au doute où j'ai
exercé pendant vingt ans la profession
de pharmacien monter un petit espace
commercial à redoute près de l'église de
route avant de redescendre en ville j
avais déjà cinq ans que j'avais quitté
la commune quand on est venu me chercher
pour faire de la politique et je n'ai
cédé d'ailleurs aux injonctions des amis
qui étaient venus me chercher que deux
ans plus tard lorsqu'on est venu me
chercher la légende dit la du cos que je
ne je n'aurais pas eu le droit à la
limite de quitter la commune à un moment
donné professionnellement il se trouve
que c'est quand j'ai eu mon nombre de
voix qui m'a permis d'entrer dans la
scène nu goossens
j'avais déjà quitté la commune depuis
plus de cinq ans donc c'est une légende
que de dire que je n'appartiens pas la
commune de ducos les gens si je vote la
ducasse d'ailleurs c'est que je suis
propriétaire à ducos un monsieur livory
c'est que je participe à l'économie de
ducos puisque j'ai monté un immeuble qui
est loué à des fins commerciales à dix
jeunes avec des loyers qui leur
permettent de s'en sortir ça veut dire
que je participe d'une certaine manière
à l'économie du cos est donc je n'ai pas
de leçon de ce goûter à recevoir en
ayant donné pendant 13 ans dans
l'associatif à lugos en donnant
aujourd'hui sur le plan commercial
je pense que les électeurs décideront
alors vous êtes président de l'ue dit
martinez et jean-françois la gare de
jean christophe lagarde sera en
martinique la semaine prochaine vous
l'avez dit quelle sera la stratégie du
parti pour les municipales émet ou des
polars du conseil sur toute l'entendue
nous aurons sur des listes aux marins
nous aurons sur des listes à trinité
avec les tâches et les chairs jeu la
personne ce alors ce sont des listes qui
sont en construction
quand elles ont annoncé officiellement
le dépôt de listes ou avant les gens
sont positionnés ce ne sont pas des
têtes de liste mais ça nous permet ce
soit pas des têtes de liste et l'accord
mais ça nous permet décès mais donc
aussi bien sur le marin aussi bien sûr
trinité aussi miesch el cheikh et
peut-être saint joseph et le président
vient vérifier tout simplement l'état de
ses troupes est particulièrement comme
nous avons un bon rapport il m'a dit
philippe si tu as besoin d'un coup de
main donc je lui fais une réunion le
mardi 12 donc la semaine prochaine je le
dis chez un ami qui s'appelle monsieur
valentin au centre du bourg neuf et
qu'il n'a jamais refusé sa maison et qui
est un du coup c'est de souche
si les pertes petit je vous remercie
bonne journée aller coûte de nos
programmes
merci beaucoup
[Musique]